here's what would happen if you fell
into the deepest hole on Earth this hole
called the cola super deep borehole is
located in Northwest Russia and is 12
kilometers deep falling to the bottom of
this hole would take over three minutes
and you'd be traveling at a speed of
over 175 kilometers per hour at first
you'd find it hard to breathe as you
pass through deadly pockets of carbon
dioxide then you'd be met with
temperatures as high as 180 degrees
Celsius hot enough to burn your entire
body in just under a second at that
point you'd probably pass out and get
burnt to a crisp but if somehow you were
still alive you wouldn't be for long
eventually you'd smack into the bottom
of the hole and be completely
obliterated so if you're anywhere near
here watch your step because